he is the number five bantamweight in
the world he is coming off a huge main
event against rob font it is cheeto vera
one of my favorite people on the ufc
roster and we had him take an uber which
i paid for all the way from orange
county during rush hour to calabasas but
he's on this week's food truck diaries
and i'm feeding them messy burgers
[Music]
good to see you again man
thank you for doing this dude appreciate
you thanks for having me
just the the
confidence man look at you dog and then
the what is what is this what is this
the rolly now i mean he can't be ranked
number five in the world not have a
rolex huh no there's a there's a ruler
in the book that say you know it's each
step you go up you gotta get something
new you have to man hi both yeah how you
feeling brother feeling great man i'm
healthy in good shape yeah i just want a
big fight but i'm
i [ __ ] let everything in the past i'm
ready to keep kicking ass and i'm
hopefully get number one contender and
get that bill later yeah because you
look at la la when last time you were on
here i mean what probably two years ago
to you wait but even before almost three
years ago you think about how your
career has evolved like
man you're coming off some
big ass wins man you know like that rob
font you know rob fonta killer dude is a
good fighter yeah and it was such a good
fight man and
you know he's obviously known you know
the new england cartel you know the
whitey bulger cartel over there so he
has great coaching that's a main event
to me it was like that fight for you
where you've had you had them hurt a
number of times
you start off a little slow which you're
kind of known for and then it was just
like this
tidal wave dude you could see i was like
man how much punishment can he take he
took a lot of damage i believe they
should stop it on round four agree but
at the end of the day it's not my
[ __ ] problem if the referee doesn't
want to stop it and the guy is tough
enough i'm going to give it to them yeah
but i think this shows what type of dude
you are and i know this you know we talk
off camera like you're such a good
person shuts a good dad you're a kid you
have such a big heart i felt like that
it could even got worse for him like you
were being cool even in that fight like
i felt like it could have got even
uglier for him yeah i thought there was
a spot that could finish it i could step
on the gas because the gasket is not an
issue for me yeah i'm running 13 15
miles
all the time so for me
i gonna step on the guys i personally
i felt i could finish it but i also felt
i wanted the five round experience and
kind of like get away with it and but i
think too and it's not rob's fault rob's
just too goddamn tough for his own good
i think he'll learn from this and come
back he's such a good fighter but i
think too a lot what saved him too is
you would rock him and be like the end
of the round
like so he'd get saved by the bell and
it was like ah that is not good man
because if there's like
you know a lot of times we'd rock him
and sit him down you know there would be
like 45 seconds of man if there was like
two minutes this thing's over so he kept
being saved by his like this weird just
you know [ __ ] happens it was almost like
the momentum of the fight was kind of
like that and i get comfy with that like
being defensive at the beginning and
just kind of like step on the gas at the
end but
a couple times i think the first time i
dropped him with the left hook i got out
of time then when i throw the heel kicks
on the face those things were pretty
they were pretty [ __ ] gnarly yeah and
then when he was going down most fires
they go crazy yes man i show experience
yeah yeah you were chill yeah i think
too in that fight
you're not a coming out party because
you've been such a staple in ufc for so
long but i think it proved that you're
ready for that next level you know like
you're ready for those cop top
contenders and they have you ranked
number five right now
and
you know with the ranking what can you
do tough i'll take top five top five
listen five can get a title shot four
can you tasha three can get a tail [ __ ]
you have to be number one so you can at
least you're in the discussion so for
you after being a main event rob font
who's a monster going from rob font
what's next like i know in the in the
news and you tell me if i'm awfulness in
the news you were talking about
dominick cruz but and i get that which i
i want to talk about but you rank the
head of donna cruz he wouldn't do it he
won't do it oh he won't do it no no they
cannot pay him enough to do it really i
don't know why
i don't [ __ ] know i i it's almost
like i already moved
away from it i was like i'm not [ __ ]
chasing you but you entertained it right
like didn't you you called him out on
the mic right i called him out right
after the fight not in the mic but i did
it after i was like hey a couple fights
ago
you were complaining
i'm below you and you only want
something ahead of you that's my
[ __ ] i'm number five right now
he don't want to do it now was that just
because it's done with cruz you don't
want the you know better weight legend
like wc legend
yeah it's as simple as he's a big name
and he's just why not but to me i don't
have [ __ ] time to
push another man to fight me i move
forward peter young called me out he's
gonna get it
peter your uncle jab he wanted i'm gonna
give it to him come get it man he will
get it because then also like and i on
you tell me i feel about i think
unfortunately fortunately and
unfortunately you know with the sugar
sean o'malley stuff obviously you have a
win over him we had him here and he you
know he won't even reference the loss
he's like ah i'm undefeated i'm like
okay you know but it's a running joke
right that's how he deals with it
but for there's always that talk like oh
we want to see sugar and cheeto again we
don't see sugar and cheeto but it's like
now especially being a guy like rob font
you know so i feel like you're in a
different category i think sugar will
get there he has the talent the kid's
[ __ ] talented man but he needs to
walk through the same fire that you walk
through and he's going to now he's
fighting you know pedro next yeah
he's a base and i think they couldn't
find him a better fight on the top 10.
you think they find that they find a
smaller guy with a shorter route it's no
i get that how are you saying advance
for sugar yeah
everything it's to benefit sugar because
even if you lost you got excuse oh for
the top guy which who [ __ ] cares yeah
i beat him when people kind of come to
me about them like i don't need that i'm
not looking hype i'm looking for three
more followers i don't give two [ __ ]
i'm making my money i'm getting up i'm
looking after the bill
i'm not looking after the hype i'm
looking after be cool because i know i'm
cool because i'm not funny i don't need
to chase that [ __ ] yeah would you try
too hard you won't get it
and the fans can smell it too i think
for sugar too it's like
it doesn't make sense
it makes sense for him because you're
five but for you it makes zero sense the
ufc
three fights agos offered me this fight
and i called my coach and we went like
this let's do this
sean shelby call him first
don't call us you know what's what's up
with us we know we're [ __ ] you'll
find anybody i fight next week is
possible i'm in shape right now
they call him they never call back i'm
like i don't even need to talk or chase
you on twitter i'm like
i already beat you yeah you you gotta
claim you you say whatever you want i
beat you you want it you can come get it
you
and any [ __ ] body yep and i think
that's why fans love you but also you
know the proof is in the pudding i mean
beating
what you did rob font was disrespectful
so and god loved you that was
disrespectful to do to rob you know what
i'm saying i know it was brutal yeah it
was great yeah it's [ __ ] great i know
he's like that's great yeah so great
yeah do it again if i have to which is
why you're gonna fight for a title i
will fight for the bell and i think this
year i saw that i sorry solidify that i
fight jan
and i guarantee everybody i stopped the
guy you guaranteed you stopped young i
stopped did you see anything with this
fight his last fight do you see anything
where you're like oh he's not maybe not
the guy because here's the thing with
peter john
for a while when he was coming up i
never gave him the respect that he
should have
got and then when he fought al germain
where he you know even though he
illegally need him i was like oh he's a
beast
like the pressure
oh yeah he got the pressure he got the
cardio he got a good snap on the punches
and he got balls
the only problem is like the whole world
make him like this
robot like he's a machine like he's on
trouble almost like hans out a little
bit right yeah [ __ ] you shoot
him in between the eyes you're gonna die
yeah you don't you don't got two dicks
you gotta have one [ __ ] thing like
well people
i don't give two [ __ ] you got two hands
two legs you're in you take a [ __ ] you
wipe the same as i do yeah [ __ ] you i'm
gonna fight you and
maybe that got to his head he thought he
was that
yeah and guys fall into that trap it's
also you know i think for for peter
young too like a fight with you makes
sense it makes all the sense of the
world for you because you're like five
what peter's probably two now he's one
is he is he still wants some as one
interesting so they have him as one
yeah so you beat him and then what do we
estimate when the fight is
he want to find october not without me
october yeah i said it's too far away
absolutely october i got two fights to
october yeah what are you talking about
twice yeah we're trying to i said let's
do it august of september in vegas we
mainly been yeah don't don't five rounds
don't run up five
six maybe we get six yeah we do six
rounds but don't get weird with october
now without the [ __ ] you know october
bro i'm we're trying to fight for a
title here i'm not wasting time i'm
running i'm [ __ ] training yeah so so
hopefully he plays ball because what are
you going to do if your manager goes hey
man so peter yon's down for the fight
they've agreed to it ufc's agreed to it
but it's only in october do you do now
i'll take somebody else earlier because
you know if you beat peter young he's
one you're one dude depends who's who
want to check the fight earlier
if the numbers make sense if number two
said like hey [ __ ] that guy i'm just
like
see ya now you don't find noah yeah
because everybody's booked now yeah now
so you have to take it and you have to
take it earlier yep because he's coming
off a loss and coming of a win great win
i know how the ufc plays great win so
and dude that win god dude that win
your family was there they came in the
freaking octagon mom dad at the apec
center it was all intimate beat the hair
[ __ ] out of a guy it was heavy
and my [ __ ] dad was
drunk and screaming do these do that
keep circling i was like calm down dad
you can hear him oh he was [ __ ] going
off he was like was he giving good tips
or was he doing like the some typical
ufc like rip his head off no he was
actually good he was like he was like
don't say that what's going on move like
he don't you don't know that word
football he will go like
clockwise yeah don't stay there and when
i would chop history it was like that's
it that's [ __ ] it i was like yeah
okay
that's the first time the whole fam came
and tell you
well my wife and kids been magnified
they're always there yeah my mom first
ever my daddy cornered him in the bus so
he'd been hitting around a little bit
but not in a main event five rounds
that's a lot of pressure too
but i just did you feel pressure i use
feet from it
everything fit negativity positivity
everything makes me good
yeah you're built for it brother i use i
use i just know how to handle it i don't
i don't i don't get off the rail because
the noise i love what other sanjia says
[ __ ] the noise like let the people let
everybody talk about it nobody's better
at than uh izzy as far as the noise
because think about the guy gets a lot
of hate in his champ for a reason he you
dude you're a [ __ ] racehorse i like
that i i go i i take that always you
take the best from people like this i'm
like i [ __ ] with that and i do the same
thing just heavy lies the crown you know
when your champ you know it comes with a
different it's a different different
game well i felt that a little bit many
ben the whole entire [ __ ] day
somebody's chasing you with a camera
you're doing more interviews than ever
oh you got
20 more things in your itinerary because
think about the ufc is banking on you to
sell this thing so to get views on espn
to sell the pay-per-view so it's like uh
if you saw uh makachev he's doing all
these hit they have a camera phone he's
doing all these interviews and uh he's
crying well he's like i don't want to do
it
and then khabib goes
this is real simple just lose this all
goes away just lose feeling like dude
just lose dude i was like oh my god
that's what makes khabib so [ __ ] you
know that that mentality man from all my
itinerary when i got it i could be like
oh we're gonna skip this and that i want
like
painful i did every single [ __ ] thing
don't [ __ ] cry
on waco day did [ __ ] go make the way
because the robbers don't even make the
way
that's right
i did everything and still make sure all
the marks boom i'm first on the [ __ ]
scale i say i'm gonna do this [ __ ]
right i don't train this [ __ ] heart
for nothing no you try and hire anybody
i know i don't remember
i don't go on sundays on my only day off
do 15 miles for nothing yeah when that
catch is locked somebody's gonna get
[ __ ] hurt yep it could be me yeah but
i do my best to don't you gotta make
sure it's not you
there's only one way to do it and it
never ends
oh bubba it's only going to get bigger
for you never end this will only like
the the interviews the the pressure the
main events the cameras the the
sponsorships the pressure from the ufc
your manager it's only for you that like
that's you know this that's your future
dude yeah it gets only you get worse and
then you go to ecuador i don't know if
you viewers know this he's tom cruise in
ecuador
he is the
he's jamie foxx in ecuador he gets
gnarly dude gnarly he goes to the house
it's for it's just it's like [ __ ]
justin bieber isn't it last last time i
visited home it was in 2019
2019's that's how you went home the last
time there's billboards and [ __ ] of them
everywhere i got my shirt ripped off in
the mall i didn't sure i didn't knew i
like you know before this trip
everybody say hi cook i didn't know you
don't know until you know
this last trip i went i took my mom to a
mall to grab a coffee i thought it was a
normal person like the last time i went
the mass of people coming at me and i
tried to just run through it
rip in your shirt break all shirt was
ripped parsley oh wow it's aggressive
mainly guys or girls
everything kids everything kids the lady
that sells plantains in the corner
everywhere knows what's up see my mind i
was in philadelphia i get harassed all
dudes just big bros hairy bro sweaty trt
now that's when you were back there in
2019 yeah imagine 2022 which you're
going there soon he's a different animal
we need security daddy i already need
security i already know i already know
has already like no let's not go to the
mall and get a cinnabon cheeto you know
yeah let's chill out i'm bringing two
thick boys with me this time yeah i wish
i could go man wish i had the time i
wish i had the time but now you now it's
just a different level dude it is it is
it's just
how life works but how proud i mean i'm
sure even your dad and mom are getting
[ __ ] they they can't believe they can
you need a cheetah to sign this glove
you know every day their mom's getting
oranges like
bro plantains
the problem
the problem the problem child becomes
something the kid that was throwing
rocks at winds going to jail for
fighting on the street
[ __ ] no making nothing right in high
school losing his gear don't pass with
the with the score to go to the next
to the other grade yeah now they're like
wow poor hit off yeah paid off i was a
[ __ ] problem you're a problem i was
god you're such a good person now back
in the day your problem huh i was a
piece of [ __ ] yeah
oh if i see a ferrari and you know
there's not many fires in ecuador i'm
like let's pick the biggest [ __ ]
brick and just [ __ ] launch it yeah
you throw a rocket one if you want to go
old school i try it yeah i tried it just
don't worry please don't throw rocks
first for fun dude really oh we will get
out of a party being all drunk
see a nice car is [ __ ] kick there
just kidding
in ecuador and just to laugh about it
yeah but i pay the price are you in a
gang no just dumb kids just you and your
boys yeah skateboards is slammed
five jesus christ dude everything now
look at you a dad imagine your kids
doing that dude oh i killed him
that's your shunned in [ __ ] 10 years
like what you been up to he's like oh
dad we saw a ferrari i think it was this
[ __ ] [ __ ] brennan shop i [ __ ]
threw a rock right through his ferrari
then i got a subreddit yeah you know
what i'm saying like it's dark dude he's
getting he's getting punched for that
he's getting punched you gotta have that
dude well you're probably not gonna
fight to maybe august peter you're on
august dude see my boy peter see my boy
john let's do this so we had some time
let me feed you let me feed you you can
go kind of gnarly because you don't have
a fight for a little bit not too crazy
because you are headed to ecuador i'm
sure the food there's gonna be
ridiculous oh my mom's home cooking
she already have a list
of all the meals i haven't eaten
oh it's [ __ ] and there's seafood out
there oh it's good oh bro like what's
your favorite dish with your mama [ __ ]
before i feed you a cheeseburger from a
food truck i think there's something
called bitching it's a what's it called
yeah v
ah yeah c-ih-e
dude it's a [ __ ] soup with soup with
um lobster
that is [ __ ] delicious like right
like what kind of biscuit kind of like a
tomato base what a time no it's like a
with um
it's not uh how you call that thing
it's not almond paste either the other
one
not almond like a peanut yeah peanut
peanut it's a peanut um
soup
with seafood bro it's like a curry it's
a it's similar color but it's with
lobster your mom puts
veggies and big boy lobsters bro oh yeah
put a little rice in there what rice you
put lime on it it's [ __ ] enough it
sounds nice i would go to ecuador just
for that but um unfortunately we don't
that food truck doesn't make that that
uh v-chain whatever and i'm gonna give
you a cheeseburger so let me feed you
and we have some time let me feed you
brother [ __ ] yeah oh my god you know i
had to do it bad like my women like my
check so make sure that it's there keep
it real and make them stand out like
comedienne standing ovation they want me
to do it again i guess that depends
let's take a little break from chatting
with my boy cheeto vera man i absolutely
love this guy it's gonna be a long food
truck because me and him we got a lot of
catching up to do but let's take a
little break cause listen man paying
down debt can be stressful
especially when you need to keep track
of multiple monthly payment dates if
you're tired of juggling due dates all
right you you need to get the loan all
down into one freaking thing so it's
easy that way you just have one due date
a month and credit karma can help you
find the best option for you my friends
at credit karma uses your credit data to
find loan offers that are personalized
to you just for you so you can have a
better idea of what loan amount you can
get approved for credit karma will even
show you your chance of approval so you
can choose between loan offers that
you're more likely to get approved on
all right and can apply for with more
confidence who doesn't want this man
comparing loan offers on credit karma is
100 percent free it won't affect your
credit score you could save money man
credit karma apply with more confidence
today ready to apply
cool head to creditkarma.com loan offers
to see personalized offers go to
creditkarma.com
loan offers that's l o a n o f f e r s
to find the loan just for you that's
credit karma.com
loan offers
what's up brother hello hello how are
you doing i'm great man thanks for doing
this definitely thank you for having us
definitely that's messy burgers man so
i'm guessing it gets pretty sloppy it
gets real messy and we keep it fresh
that's how we do it fresh and messy not
mad at man
what do you uh what do you recommend my
man the burgers definitely are our top
seller your go-to the messy burger
ground beef all fresh all the time and
um definitely handmade so definitely i
would definitely suggest that about that
i was gonna say the chicken sandwich
buttermilk battered we flour it to order
so it's definitely good and then we also
got our loaded fries which are pretty
good we got a buffalo chicken fries we
got pesto chicken fries
um and then we got our bacon
cheeseburger fries that's our little uh
load extra loaded fries
it sounds like it's pretty messy it gets
very nice in my pants uh what are you
gonna go with cheeto i'll go with the
burger you going this one the classic
where you going cheeseburger
cheeseburger
sounds good to me everything on it okay
everything sounds good
uh also do the classic messy burger uh
no bun for your boy here
and then let's also do uh we'll try the
buffalo chicken fries buffalo fries
all right
we'll uh get that done in about five
minutes just wait over
[Music]
this is
[Music]
let's take another little break from
chatting and grabbing down with cheeto
vera man cause the kings of crotch
comfort are back
you've heard me talk about manscape
before that's right manscape they spent
two years designing the most comfortable
boxer briefs on the planet all right
i've had the honor of testing these bad
boys out and i can say it's the softest
softest fabric ever that mo doll i think
it's called maldol we get to that but
it's so freaking soft and breathable
it's like gills for your piece gill
imagine if your piece had gills could
breathe and just get air that's what
this is like man they even trademarked
the jewel pouch all right that because
they in these boxes they have an area
that was designed for your three-piece
set
designed for it the jewel pouch they
trademarked it that's how good it is
because they care about your piece when
you don't man you've been abusing that
thing all your life beating them up left
and right when you're a teenager you're
just beating the hell out of that thing
once you take care of them show them a
little respect all right that's where
jewel pouch comes in man listen let your
bulge breathe
give them what they deserve you've been
beating that thing up since you're a kid
get 20 off all right you can get 20
percent off man and listen for you out
there you guys are on ryer all these
weird apps you got the date coming up if
they see manscaped on your freaking
waistline like say what yeah dude
everybody knows it's the jewel pouch a
pouch designed to cradle your boys with
a special space all right it's lined
with
performance fabric to keep it ventilated
who cares more about your three-piece
set than manscape the answer is nobody
the micro model that's what i'm talking
about dude the micro moldol it's so
freakin buttery it's so soft i'm telling
you you're never gonna want to wear
anything else tagless waistband hugs
your body without digging into your
freaking
sides you know what i'm saying guys you
know what i'm talking about you got the
spills over the top not with this man we
got you covered man the front fly opens
easy access all right because you got to
pee real fast we got you man you can
choose from an arrangement of designs
and colors and sizes ready small to 3xl
sun for all you thick boys out there 3xl
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code shop20 manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code shop20
manscape.com
once the boxers 2.0 touch your sack you
never go back
let's dig on in my man you got your
standard uh tossed egg on that thing
it's not as messy as you'd think
that's pretty nice man it's not it looks
good it looks
tasty yeah mine looks awful because i'm
i don't need carbs i try not to you know
getting carbs you know what dude
when you'll see when you retire you got
to be careful man because how old are
you
29 29 okay you have some time i i'm 39.
i had 10 years on you dude
you'll see man your metabolism slows
down and then when you're on stage you
want to be you know yeah you'll be
careful i'll get big dude like before i
start the stabs 270. six four 270 i mean
what are we doing you know what i'm
saying run yeah or just don't eat
don't eat and get stressed out dude it's
the best diet in the world
it happens every camp you know the last
month you're not thinking about anything
but making weight you forget about your
fighting
but this is the shitty thing what i love
about you
well i lost about a bunch of guys
some some
between fights when they're cutting
weight they blow up
i did a food truck paddy pimlet
that boy is every bit of 215.
it's huge
he blows up
he blows up that's bad for you
that's a short career guy right there
yes bad idea god bless him but that's a
short career
but then you you're i mean you're in
shape what are you 150ish 152 right now
i like i prepped for this yeah when you
text me
well seven days ago yeah i eat
less it cleaner because i knew i would i
was cheating today i planned these
things yeah you're such a professional
man like i can go out with friends
everybody can you know [ __ ] around drink
i take a couple hits from a joint but i
don't eat the pizza
i don't eat the extra snacks i don't
it's just not worth it
but also as a professional like this is
your job you want to disrespect the
craft and it's like
that's that's like you never know like
let's say which i definitely want your
opinion on let's say algerian tj right
let's say
heaven forbid al germain hurts his
shoulder
and the man who's ready to go and you
know everybody's fat
everyone's out of shape but they go
cheetos actually always in shape call
cheeto and you get this
late
notice short replacement title shot they
the ufc knows
that i'm
i have a deal with them that i said like
if i break my finger i call you and tell
you
don't call me in the next three weeks
but if i haven't told you my finger is
broken i fight any weekend of the year
i've been doing commentary on a saturday
and a five fell through and it takes
dana
i mean i'm here really let's do it
really check my weight i'm not even
overweight it's not even like
like a bad thing i'm like 150. at 35 i
can't get more than that so did you uh
what's your opinion on the the you know
charles oliveira fought he won but he
was they were saying that this skeleton
is like kilograms to weight so if a
fighter which the majority of them that
aren't in north america they always deal
with kilograms so they got to change the
weight do you have any issues i think
that's [ __ ] because that's a bottom
you go like this kilograms two pounds
and you check your way every time i go
to check my weight 18 kilograms because
the brazilians i used to do kilograms
but now i get used to pounds so i
changes two pounds
and your weight is aware like the ufc
scales are calibrated unless somebody
jump on it or kick it or they move it
from point a to b
they may change but those scales are
like they're on it oh they're on it so
you're not buying it
well i don't know the story right yeah
they said i guess like a bunch of
fighters were like like doing stuff
before you know so maybe that threw it
off this is one thing that threw me off
normally and you know this we do
two
free checks correct you do one check in
the hotel
a pre-check with ufc people on the blue
shirt checking in right when you get in
on tuesday usually right on tuesday but
this is your wedding day on one day you
check
on the closest scale to your room and
then the blue the blue shirt people will
be like bear right some way whatever on
the mic
then you go to the car you drove to the
apex or to the arena and then before you
go down the stage or before you go to
sit down they check you again oh so they
know oh you know when you're not making
weight yeah so that's what when if they
if they do two pre-checks and this is
the ufc fault or the scale fall this
will a way bigger problem okay if
only beta was 0.5 over
that's on him
unless somebody told me something i
don't know because they they do like i
walk out of my room on friday morning
and you go and check
on the lobby
and they say like he's on weight they
tell you don't drink don't eat don't
[ __ ] move keep it here you jump in
the car once you get in the apex because
mayan
he he was in a different state but
once you get to the apex they check the
weight one more time just to make sure
just to make sure and then there's like
four guys with blue shirt around the
scale looking and that's the commission
no that's it no that's a blue shirt
people oh the commercial is not even
here the commission only checked once
you're in the official scale
on camera
yeah so it'd be nice if somebody from
the ufc came it's weird they're not
going because i think it would clear a
lot up if they went right before he got
on he was on weight then he uses that
scale and it's a half pound over but
they didn't say that no one said
anything so that means he when he
checked on the usual scale he was off he
was lost it was off and
that's not one problem i saw him on
wednesday hitting me with plastics
that's not a good sign right that's too
early to start cutting away like on
wednesday i would do like a a hard
meat workout i would do a little sauna
but it's almost to get a sweat going if
your own plastics going on
you're probably cutting a lot of weight
see but and this is the advantage you
have keeping it professional because a
lot of those guys they gotta cut all
that weight so day up to the weigh and
they're killing themselves
if you hang around a manageable weight
that's the discipline like you like
tell the fighters that that blow up
between fights and they got to kill
themselves make weight like you don't
think cheeto wants to chill and eat
burgers every [ __ ] day and do all
that stuff but as a professional good
job yeah and then it pays off for you
during fight week and then you're
healthier yes
your brain don't get [ __ ] up you can
definitely take a better shot you can
recover if you get hit and
i'm focusing on the skills i'm focused
on getting better as a fighter not
cutting weight i'm not going to wait
three months before i fight yeah three
months before a fight i do wear the
[ __ ] one because whatever the [ __ ]
one for me is steak liver vegetables
high fats
like good nutrients like dense nutrients
like i'm not [ __ ] around junk food
and i already i already enjoyed that
yeah like i eat fruit
i ate a steak yup i eat veggies
vegetable juice
i'm not [ __ ] wrong i'm like i put
like this it's like a [ __ ] surgeon a
guy that do
open hearts that [ __ ] after each
uh operation don't go on a [ __ ]
cruise no he knows he goes to the
[ __ ] hospital he's not getting
hammered coming in hung over you know
not really so most of these athletes
they think they're rockstars i'm gonna
let the rappers be rappers we're [ __ ]
athletes yep like just because you hang
out with a cool guy that's something you
can drink all the [ __ ] day yeah but
most athletes don't get it because it's
all hype and they think that oh i saw
[ __ ]
lil wayne drink drinking tequila yeah
that's [ __ ] really weird yeah he
don't use his body though he used his
[ __ ] tongue to do
yeah be cool yeah was that you rabbit
yeah that's me rob yeah i'll take it
though oh it's so good i was sick uh i
just don't get the
the fat fight i'm like it's it's it's
yeah i
like with patty he has this have you
been around patty never like with patty
he has like this um
i don't know if it comes across on uh
cameron i didn't watch the food i don't
watch anything i do but in interviews
with that maybe it comes across or maybe
it does i don't know but he just has
this
uh vibe about him like it's a fun vibe
like he's just like a like you can tell
he's just like a good happy kid from
liverpool you know and he's doing his
thing he's confident in it you know so i
i for him i don't think it's like such
as uh
even though he blew the [ __ ] you know
the liverpool thick boy like he is big
man but for him it it doesn't come off
as like i got this or arrogant he's just
like ah i'm fun man he seems he seems
like a really nice cool guy really nice
so i i'm not i'm not against that
basically your career can be very short
if you keep [ __ ] around like that
yeah because you can get away the first
come the second camp but keep adding to
you every fight come take a little bit
out of you every fight take a little
every wake up especially when you get to
the top because you need the the
slightest advantage to win that fight
yeah if if you're more concerned about
cutting weight than working on skills it
catches up i always talk about it it's a
[ __ ] scale
it's a what it's a scale you [ __ ] around
you're drinking you're
smoking too much start going like that
yeah
but then you're like sleeping well
eating correctly going to bed telling
your friends you're not going out and
do consistently over time
how you lose yeah you're [ __ ] doing
everything possible i'm with you let me
just leave you to [ __ ]
to the fight you just go and fight your
ass off yep and yeah and the rest takes
care of it how come fighters on the
first round
[ __ ] feign they die i'm like you turn
every day yeah what do you mean five
minutes you you get tired yeah also you
don't meant a mental focus it's
mentality experience
but over here you're not because at some
point i was six and one and the youtube
side of me i got nine i got 25 with the
ufc now jesus christ i have no
experience at the beginning
i lost because of his kill i never got
tired in a fight no yeah because you can
control that it's imagined on you yeah
that's on you like if you you people
freaked out you're cool if i drink it
all right
let me give it to you
so most of my friends are coming so you
can't drink around
let's take another little break from
chatting and grubbing down with cheeto
vera last break promise this is the last
one guys please listen to this all right
listen right now the gyms are packed
everybody's coming back society is back
but you're still like i'm good man the
the maybe your fee at the gym is crazy
high maybe trying to save money maybe
you just don't want to be around all
these people all right you don't need to
do that because you can get a great
workout at your home uh listen i've been
a peloton guy for six years my name on
there is thick boy perez with a z you
can see me under the user on there
my obsession with bikes started with
peloton i was doing it in the my garage
man 20 minutes 30 minutes 45 minutes
robin's my favorite trainer i'm doing in
the garage i thought let's take this to
the streets but guess what now i miss my
freaking peloton man because so much fun
they have world-class instructors i'm
working out to great music if time flies
by i'm burning hundreds and thousands of
calories easily i'm getting my sweat on
you can do it from the comfort of your
home again pelton has a team of
world-class instructors that are ready
to motivate you 24 7. it's never the
same it's not if you're that person i
like the same workout you do the same
one i guess but if you like new stuff
fresh keep you motivated peloton's for
you man pelton has thousands of live and
on-demand classes who can always keep it
fresh from cycling to strength training
yoga running they even added boxing
that's right dude there's pelton boxing
man you get your workout and learning to
fight a little bit all right uh pelton
fits seamlessly into your life maybe
you're looking for a 10 minute upper
body strength workout between calls you
have the 40 minute run before bed pelton
works with your schedule when you're
ready to go pelton's always there it's
like a trusted friend you have you ever
had a trainer that's around 24 7 that's
peloton daddy that's peloton all right
and right now it's the perfect time to
try out peloton because the pelton bike
plus is now 500 buckaroos less than it's
ever been it's the best price it
includes free delivery and setup for you
and there's more game changing prices
available on the original pelton bike
which i have they also have the pelton
tread that's the treadmill right you
know this visit onepeloton.com to learn
more that's
to onepeleton.com more one peloton.com
to learn more peloton
you know i don't
yeah it's tough man but i continue to do
it but um the other thing i want to get
your take on this especially you've had
20 fights in the ufc you know the number
five guy in the world you fought
main event you know big fights jose aldo
sugar shot rob font all these monsters
that you fought
you know
and i don't know the fans i was talking
about this on the shop show on monday
about the the judging if you if if you
if you realize
it is to become this reoccurring theme
throughout the us throughout our sport
where it's like can't leave the hands of
the judges and then on for friends i
don't know this when you're fighting ufc
dana white after weins gives you like
this rah-rah speech and it's good and he
always leaves don't leave in the hands
of the judges they're not good like you
can't do that you can't count on them
which he does it for multiple reasons a
he's right b
if you're planning to go decision it's
not going to be that fun of a fight so
he needs exciting fights he needs
finishes but then to his point if you
look to the judges anything goes and i
think the biggest problem in mma right
now currently right now it's been going
on for years but no one has really
addressed it and now it's coming to
light a little more because it's a real
problem
is
our we are conditioned you me the the
fighters the fans the ufc staff the
owners the the media everyone goes ah
that's judging it's like no no hold on
hold on it's no that doesn't work for me
because any other sport isn't going to
allow that we're not they're not going
to put up with it but for a reason the
mma fan base goes it's the judges they
get used to that it's almost like they
everybody just accepted that's what i'm
saying like it's nuts to me
and those judges over there like
the guys are watching a fight and saying
nine or ten
what are their experience what they're
because some states qualify at tech nine
if you have one take down but they're
going to [ __ ] you up other states
appreciate more boxing so it's like
other person more grappling he's like i
think we should go in and say hey this
is arizona over here you're punching
suck so we want grappling like at least
you know what you're getting into it see
but even then you that's a problem like
imagine
uh
what sport do you like [ __ ] soccer i
guess in ecuador soccer is your [ __ ]
i always surf i i surf i never get
that's not going to work
with soccer we can go with soccer let's
say in soccer uh and this is to your
point which people will say this so
let's say you love to watch soccer in
the world cup ecuador's in the world cup
they're in the [ __ ] final match
but the referee
uh is more into
my school kicks if you do a bicycle kick
you get three points if you do a regular
kick you get one point and that's his
preference yeah imagine that dude where
they're like oh yeah actually that kit
counts as three points because this ref
prefers absolutely you'd be like what
the [ __ ] no it should be equal anywhere
we play we shouldn't dictate based off
the bias of the judges but like who who
are
who they are who's a commission what
what they do like well most of them come
from a boxing background it's a boxing
commission even even those guys that
judge fights
in mma they're
referees in boxing yes like how in the
[ __ ]
you say like it's just an opinion when
there's a real close fight it's just a
[ __ ] opinion you look at holly holm
vera and uh dc uh
and i didn't see dc's thing i did a
similar rant where it's like
you know holly which controlled the
fight and had vera against her back
against the cage vera i guarantee you
guys going into that fight her coach
didn't go okay make sure your back's
against the cage holly's doing a an
action that is there doesn't want to be
against cage so that would be winning
the fight but if you're a judge and you
don't really know what's going on or you
don't care about gun control you care
about damage you're getting the fight to
vera when holly was winning the majority
i watched it i that day
i turned off my phone because i wasn't
what i don't watch the fight's life i
normally go
bottom to top non-stop me too so i turn
off my phone the main event i turn up my
phone i get to my house like around
eight o'clock at night and i just replay
everything from the beginning not
knowing what happened and i was like
i was expecting the judges to raise her
hand i was like oh that's kind of weird
but that was like okay you gotta
re-watch it to have an opinion but they
might saw the whole world complaining
about it but that will change but that's
the other problem we have in mixed
martial arts it's like that's not
holly's fault or vieira's fault or any
close decision when a fighter loses it
sucks for both of them but
you know
social media and even the the the
analyst or even to me i don't think they
should mic up the cornermen because if
you can hear what the cornerman is
saying so viera's corners basically
saying she's lost every round well if
the audience hears that they're going oh
yeah she's losing
instead of coming up with their own
original opinion everything from social
media to the coaching the analysts it's
all swaying people a certain direction
so people aren't coming up with their
own original organic ideas no one's have
one everybody just repeat what they say
they seem like oh bernie shop say this
okay i'm gonna tweet that oh this is it
i'm gonna tweet that but yes
i like to
s when i wanna say something i see the
opinions but i wanna come with my own
not everybody do that yeah and
also in the counting the counting
because the person that counts is not
the person that judge
so if you're counting one or landed
landed landed
if somebody threw a job and i go
blog with my forum is that a land job
yeah you pair
and also is that person counting like
for those copy strike numbers that they
give us and significant damage how many
times how many times have they been hit
how many times have they trained to have
that uh authority i have this this is
the best analogy on my last fight rob
threw like
300 like land 300 and i landed like
120 it was it was a crazy amount so when
they have the stat
oh rob won the fight and it's like yeah
it's cute but it's like how many punches
he did land yes how many punches was
elbow elbow block block
whatever you cannot explain that to
these joys because they're [ __ ]
dinosaurs but
go off who got damaged because it's like
if you see the blocks the person that
counts have the high speed to be like oh
that was a bear another okay all this
that was oh that land length oh that was
a bird that was a bird yeah unless it's
floyd mayweather i'm not trying to hear
it dude yeah you know from these old
dinosaur judges but it's also to your
point where you know if they're you
can't dictate a fight just off output
because let's say for your next fight
against peter young let's say it's in
august let's hope that happens
and going into that fight let's say it's
in vegas and it's at mgm or where the
hell you're going to do it at and your
this is what i worry about now your
coach because it's such an issue at your
level too
i would love for you to go in there and
wheel kick peter yon's face off in one
second and get out of it and fight for
the title that's what i hope happens
everybody it's [ __ ] at your level
those guys are [ __ ] good you didn't
do that so there's a good chance it goes
to the judges the problem is when it
goes to the judges when they don't know
what they're watching do that and you
lose half your pay and then everyone
just chucks up goes part of the game
don't leave to the hands of the judges
like wait no hold on but you going into
that now what makes more pressure on you
and your coach now you have to find out
who the judges are and go all right what
did they score in the past oh this is
the same judge that didn't really care
about output cared more about damage oh
this this judge cares about octagon
control so then you have to game plan
tailoring it to these incompetent judges
in 2022 it's mind-blowing to me to beat
this to beat whatever you say
the best thing you can do goodness you
guys no no just above like and don't let
none of that get in your head and just
be like this is another fight
[ __ ] everything it's me and this
[ __ ] and just
come as prepared as you can
and just [ __ ] hope for the best
i'm with you and that's exactly what you
should do because there's no the problem
is the culture
that's my problem see but i if we go
there's never gonna be changes nothing
will ever get done
i hope for the change yeah but it's like
you're not banking on it
you can't but also it's out of your
control is that and what it say do not
worry about you can look yeah don't
focus on things i worry them [ __ ] i
can put an extra mile i can get my
boxing better i can start a little
faster in the first round the rest is
out of my hands yep well i don't fight
so i'll [ __ ] worry about i didn't
sleep last night going through different
scenarios i have anxiety drive me crazy
i'm a fighter i watch every single car
and sometimes i'm like
why do you [ __ ] score like what are
you [ __ ] talking about also like even
that rob
rob font fight
like if you look how close that fight
was again finished and a lot of things
that you did i'm like well those are
clearly 10 eight rounds
i'm how the [ __ ] did did they not score
and i think one of them or two of them
did but across the board how are those
not 10 8 rounds explain that to me it
was full dominance it was like yes i did
wear the [ __ ] one yes
going to the fifth round i i asked for
real i'm a coach i'm winning this fight
right because
because these judges are crazy he's like
you are winning on my eyes i can say
this [ __ ] my eyes go and finish him
but and see that's what to me is so
alarming imagine any other major league
sport imagine if the dallas cowboys
playing the devil broncos and they go
and the the dallas head coach goes uh
hey guys
just so you know this ref
doesn't value passing he only values
running so let's run the way we're going
to win is we have to run more he's like
that's [ __ ] insane but in mma we go
that's how it goes you're right no
you're right it's nuts i'm with you yeah
it's nice but you shouldn't worry about
let me worry about it i'll have to sleep
it's nice and worry about it and
it's [ __ ] crazy
any crazy
i believe
even if with shitty judges
if they say in the scream who won the
wrong life
then i can be like i get robbed now i
want to [ __ ] you up at least i can
change the energy yeah a lot of because
i think uh dc i saw on shop show chim
brought it up where someone goes what
about open scoring and a big john i
don't think likes open scoring either i
don't know a lot of people that like
open scoring the reason i like open
scoring is because at least you can get
at least you know at least the guy who
even if he's winning and he's like what
that doesn't count then you can adapt
and kind of change the trajectory of the
fight and let's see
they give the other guy the round that
you clearly won and they're just like
[ __ ] it i'm winning this fight let me
just try to hug you yes that's the bet
that's the easiest time to hurt somebody
when you're aborting the fight you're
playing a second yeah you just [ __ ]
throw that that's what i think dana said
open scoring he's like the problem with
that is let's say it's a five-round
fight and let's say like your rob
uh fight for example let's say the you
know uh first round second third you
start taking over but let's say you're
up three rounds at zero and you see it
on the open scoring that fourth and
fifth i think what dana and the ufc
staff is worried about is oh people are
going to start holding back playing it
more safe if it's open scoring if they
don't know they're like oh i gotta get
this guy that's fine but let's see
i'm three rounds up
i will [ __ ] never
get in that shield because that's that's
the easiest way to get hurt that's you
though brother you know what i'm saying
there's other guys that are i [ __ ] go
to hell i if i'm losing three rounds i
bring the [ __ ] up you're behind me
you're an ecuadorian banshee if you're
down three rounds yeah you know been
down three rounds but if i am i'm
[ __ ] yeah you better come i bring
some hay to that [ __ ] uh let's
move on for this because we're never
going to solve it here um yes i get
fired up about it dude i think i haven't
tried it i get i i couldn't sleep last
night thinking about it it happened to
me before i lose half of my money and
you [ __ ] and the whole and
entire world is like [ __ ] that you won
that will help doesn't help so same
exact thing granted one of the bonus
fights in ufc heavyweight history i beat
andre alaska i beat him so bad in the
back he goes you won that fight dude
here i'm going to give you my winning my
win purse i go dude it's not your fault
you did what you're supposed to do the
judges [ __ ] it up i won that fight
what fans don't understand what the
public understand is
it when you get screwed over in a fight
like you're talking about you got
screwed over
what they don't realize you're getting
half your pay you're getting half your
pay your coaches are getting half their
pay your entire training camp your kids
school your your mortgage your life
your life is a half so imagine at work
if you didn't know what the what the
boss respected and you hand in your
final project he goes ah man i want you
to use whatever uh some other format
it's not the format we're gonna give you
half your salary would you guys be like
uh that's how it goes
it's so [ __ ] up and then on top of
that you cannot move up on the rankings
you cannot fight something better and
you cannot ask for more because you're
coming off a loss and the ufc hold
against you lost the loss you're like
what you know i won like sorry dude like
it's on here it's the last you're like
so you're [ __ ] and also especially in
your weight class
it's murder's row so one loss you're
going back in the queue you're gonna
have to walk through a [ __ ] demon to
get back to where you're at probably a
few demons
yeah call but no one
but again everyone just goes part of the
sport that's not working for me all
right let's move on because i'm gonna go
nuts um
tj dillashaw algerian sterling
how you feel about it i gotta go with tj
just because i got a more personal
relation with him training out here in
orange county so we trained for a while
before and
i just feel
he have
he's a real wrestler
you know he can
fullerton like he can defend the
integrand
and in the striking
in the stand up
al-jamin is a great athlete
but he isn't a fighter he's not a
fighter you only use fire oh and he's an
athlete i bet my house he's not a
fighter yeah if [ __ ] goes sideways he
will give up interesting yeah tj will
not tj
lance armstrong yeah he's he's not
saying pds i'm saying like his mentality
yeah i'm saying like you're gonna have
to kill that yeah you gotta you gotta
put him on a fighter's fighter or you're
gonna kick his ass but all you've been
shown in the past
he did it with asunzado with brian
carter with that's how much of mma watch
he just
if things go sideways for him he's like
yeah you can take it i can live another
day in with other guys like tj or myself
i'm like [ __ ] you i'm dying right now
you kill me right now because i'm not
going home like a little [ __ ]
interesting but
alien it's a great athlete with the
great wrestling
because he's here too
he's good to you just on top
he's good at taking the back when guys
like
jan defend by giving the back different
like insane i'm a i'm a grappler i'm not
giving you my bug ever
take my back like aldo did
i find my ass off to get out hell yeah
i'm not just that's jujitsu what's life
or that young was like
yeah he was chilling it was like what to
do here yeah i i stand up twice and put
out like even in that round with aldo i
did more work than he did i agree but it
is what it is i'm not going there but i
believe
um t you have the wrestling
to stop the taking and then the standard
you have to fight yeah and his cardio is
not so he's got cardio both have cars
and then tj here mentality wise there's
nobody stronger he's very competitive so
competitive so that's a good fight it's
it all comes in how healthy tea it is
it's coming of a knee a heavy injury
and like
you're not getting younger so like all
that we just don't know he knows how he
feels about that and ollie is a little
younger so maybe that can help him
if it was up to you would you rather
fight al germain or tj so if you get
through peter yan when you get through
patreon would you rather fight al
jermain or tj
i personally don't like audio so we like
to kick his ass well
you don't like him because you don't
think he's a real fighter
i don't like his personality he is a
little [ __ ] he's a little diva so i
don't like the guy did that come from
when he got illegally need from peter
young no way before this comes when
years ago when he fought uh brian carter
we started crying like a little [ __ ]
yeah i don't get promoted this and that
i usually like okay bro you want to get
comments on your face they promote it he
went and looks like a like a little
[ __ ] yeah card and that rubbed you the
wrong way i was like ah [ __ ] this guy's
crying for attention they giving
attention and then goes on fire like a
[ __ ] i'm like
what you want you want to be famous you
want to be a fighter yeah so it's just
like it's a little dorky guy like he
would talk online but face to face he
wouldn't do nothing i punch in the face
if you want it yeah but then when we saw
charlie's like ah kind of like uh yeah
whatever yeah i'm down for that stuff
and dude you know i love you you know
this like you're such a fighters fighter
i think that's why people are drawn to
you and then you also have a great
personality and then you're a great dad
and
off you're the number [ __ ] five guy
in the world i think she'll be retired
but that's not my choice so you have all
this stuff going for you and i know
you're down to fight whether it was on
the street or in the octagon
but there is a thing because when you
look at like what mozvidal did to kobe
covington it's to me i go well
sucker punching a guy isn't gangster
like that that mentality like yeah
that's like [ __ ] it's [ __ ] you
gotta tell the guy hey let's go tight or
hey get ready correct like a man i'll be
like yo i'm here i'm gonna kick your ass
you you fight or you run
but from behind
i can do it yeah i love jorge that's my
boy
mazdal one of my favorite he was on here
he's such even if you talk about his
wife and kid i will face him first i
would come from
from the front i wouldn't come from
behind yeah and yeah yeah you know i'm
from miami from the streets i get that
and maybe it's because the streets of
denver are different but it's like the
sucker punching like to a guy that's not
prepared there's nothing gangster about
that sir there's nothing there's nothing
hard about it no there's not time
like that's for [ __ ] that's for
people that don't have hoary skills
that's what they do
and that disappointed me and i think he
realized he kind of messed up there
and then also what disappoints me is
colby pressing charges it's like you
guys go back so far dude you guys used
to be roommates i get it [ __ ] up your
tooth all that i [ __ ] up the rolex
scratch the rolex you don't sue the guy
this if i'm kobe that's what i do i tell
the ufc hey i'll drop the charges if you
put me and him in the main event again
let me beat his ass and pay me more
pay-per-view points because otherwise
he's me on the shelf
getting sued right
that's a good negotiation that's a good
point but
look
if if a fighter i like a
like a real person like kobe not a not a
troll talk about my wife and kids
i will fly somewhere to find you i i'm
not going to play this game like oh [ __ ]
your mother too i'm like or i'll usually
wait no
i'm going to be like i'm here i'm going
to run to you and yeah you're not going
to suck a punch i think from behind yeah
i don't know the past it doesn't feel
good it doesn't feel good yeah but i did
it together that was beating my friends
it was kind of like what do you mean in
the past
a guy was kicking my friends as too bad
nice one like you know [ __ ] it
boom yeah i get it your buddy's gonna
beat up you gotta get it and then
they're all his friends so i kind of
like paid it but just like if you see
your enemy sitting there
now you're gonna go like that i would
yell his name and be like get ready
[ __ ] there's no respect in that
there's not yeah i think jorge is
learning the hard way right now you know
it's a bummer it's a bomber it's a
[ __ ] bomber [ __ ] yeah from behind
how where are you at uh because again
you're a fighters fighter were you at on
like the jake paul logan paul stuff like
these youtube fights i [ __ ] like it
very good for them like [ __ ] dude
they're making money for you i don't
hate on that yeah you can hate on
somebody that is
doing well yeah doesn't matter unless
you're you know killing people or
stepping on people doing it the the
wrong way yeah they're like oh you're a
piece of [ __ ] they're [ __ ] great dude
yeah i'm happy for them i don't [ __ ]
know them maybe i i like them maybe i
know they've shot their hands like them
yeah but i'm like i'm mistake about i'm
like these [ __ ] came from [ __ ]
these
these are like dancing with [ __ ]
ballet dresses another [ __ ] badass
somebody's good for you yeah making all
the money mickey
[ __ ] dude
joe paul was on forbes top
i think 40 richest athletes he was like
44 million this year good
he was on disney
everybody dude he was dancing ballet not
a while ago yeah and right now he's
[ __ ] on top pillow of money
hey
good for you [ __ ] yeah that's
where i'm at high five i don't hate i
don't know
but why people hate them
two reasons
they got more money than the hater yep
and they got more attention to the hater
correct and the head is a [ __ ] loser
that don't fit for nothing and only get
[ __ ] dry yeah they're what yeah
they're mad they're like it's it's it's
a reflection on themselves they're much
they're there's a hater [ __ ] that guy
yeah you made it because you're fighting
all guys hey those two old guys that he
beat
they were in the ufc yeah so somehow
those two old guys are kind of badass so
i give it to him yeah man and he put our
coal
both of them
both of them yeah respect dead face down
ass up i'm like respect i don't dislike
them that's my same thing with like
francis and tyson fury and i've had uh
friends on her you know a bunch i love
francis and
i want the tyson fury fight for him
do i think he's gonna be tyson no no no
come on what i want the fight for him
because i want him to make more money
than god because what you guys have put
yourself through and the sacrifice
you've made with your family and you
know and you're not compensated how you
should be but you know they're trying
their best different conversation but
with francis it's like i want him to get
even if he goes in there and gets
knocked out in three seconds
he's still making his kids kids kids
kids kids are [ __ ] set financially he
will send that check man that's what i
want for him yeah yeah i don't get why
people hate on that stuff i
but that's the thing with that's the
problem with social media today it's so
powerful that all these
undercover [ __ ] yes have an opinion
that's the
great thing about me i learned from
[ __ ] the godfather right there
joe rogan yes pause and drop post in
ghost or drop a drop okay don't go and
read what they say if if i want to check
what my mom says i [ __ ] call this
beautiful lady i'm not i'm not oh my
[ __ ] you and your mother your piece of
[ __ ] your daughter will die i'm like ah
yeah this isn't good
just
social media is so powerful that all
these opinions and now we see even if we
don't want to see them they're there if
you subscribe to it if you give social
media that power i don't give that [ __ ]
but what we're seeing is like you're
seeing a lot of celebrities and athletes
for that matter
you're who are i think are leading by
example and even a lot of comics too
like if i do a set i'm not reading
comments man i know where i messed up i
don't want i've never had someone give
me a comment where i'm like oh that's a
good note i'm going to use that in my
neck never never as a fighter i never
read a comment oh you're right i should
have used this more because they you
know if you post a video grappling
bro
you gotta box more bro you gotta kick
box let me put a video throwing a
hundred kicks bro come on get that
wrestling sharper i'm like
it's been like six years that i don't
pay attention and i'm a happy person
yeah and some of my friends they're
[ __ ] on a bottle obsessed with them
they're like defending are you fighting
with your wife i know and it's like no
it's [ __ ] i'm like
calm down click
have zero followers got no picture
[ __ ] get it together yeah get a
[ __ ] loser too yeah in and out and to
your point the godfather with rogan you
know he's a guy where
especially during the height of the
vaccine stuff and they he got to me
that's when i learned that and even
that's when i dropped my own special my
own network because it's like as
comics you see everybody wants that
validation from hollywood then when i
saw hollywood turn their back on rogan i
saw the way the media treats rogan i'm
like oh i'm not like i'm out man i'm not
like them i'm out i'm gonna do it almost
they were attacking him i will say stuff
in spanish like hey [ __ ] everybody
that's talking [ __ ] to him i got a lot
of backlash in ecuador
guess what
suck my dick from like my opinion yeah
like eat it on
with balls deep down
i don't need you yeah it's just my
opinion but i also i'm not scrolling
finding all of them no yeah but also
it's like what you're trying to
accomplish you can't
you can't put power into the opinion of
social media
anybody who's doing anything worth the
work worth uh doing no one's making sure
that they're validated from social media
i think as time goes on more
public figures when they speak about
that because i know it's so many people
that don't they go i post you have to
but then i don't read anything i think
the more people are outspoken about the
more it's to educate the the youngsters
because what the junctures see they see
they will find
somebody with
some kind of push
that do something really stupid and they
want to like oh that's the way i'm like
no it's not gonna work like that for you
if you go like for example the the drama
between kobe and jorge yeah these kids
go to high school hey i'm the [ __ ] your
mom
and that'll go well yeah i don't but to
me uh in this way i started the switch
talking about somebody's wife yeah i
don't i don't know when it became okay
to talk to
your opponent like that and
like
again in all other sports i know ufc is
different that's why it's grown so big
but
i don't know when it was okay to step
across that line and bring family into
it or religion because because there's
no
let's say i going online and i go on one
of these guys and just say
put a comment on his
anybody with a wife and be like [ __ ]
wanna take her the uc will
maybe the pr will be like hey delete
that but i don't get a 50 000 fine which
i should yeah i agree and
that's why most of them get balls
they're like you know what i can do this
i can [ __ ] but they also they're
doing because they know it's going to
get attention too they got because
social media the algorithm is set up for
to the most views negativity is that
what
is what is promoted in the algorithm
which isn't good but look look what
happened guys like call me and start
finding now oh your wife this your mom
this your kid is
you get soccer punch i don't respect
that
i will hope you got a baseball bat and
put on his [ __ ] knees yeah and just
tore everything
i go to yo i'm pissed yeah because i'm
like you don't talk about my wife and
kids and if you do
you're gonna pay the price yeah i'm
[ __ ] full yep i'm not gonna talk but
i will see you one day yep that's what
and i don't talk about no one's wife or
kids either i'd be so disappointed if
you did i can do that you know you never
would though like fighters aren't really
doing that but i think what gave kind of
the floodgate for that to be accepted is
connor with with khabib you know where
he's talking about your wife
your wife and the muslim and so i think
fighters go oh well he
uh
monetization-wise is the most successful
guy to ever do it so that's what the ufc
likes so then the ufc didn't discipline
for throwing the you know the [ __ ]
dolly and all that stuff so i think
fighters went okay that's how i make all
the money and it's like no it's not dude
what happened if that dolly would get
some like rainbow got
[ __ ] nothing hot but he got glass on
the eye who's that raver yeah ray borg
uh rose i was gonna petrify well i
believe that though they hit somebody on
the side of the neck
yeah
we wouldn't be talking about it right
now but it's like the ufc didn't come
down harsh enough on connor because he's
such a he's the biggest name ever he's
the biggest so i think it somehow the
lines got blurred and once the
toothpaste is out of the thing you can't
put it back in so now they're like well
and then they have a guy with is one
around the ufc going crazy he's like ah
bro not you
but that's the narrative it's like okay
how i get good
yup i'm with you brother well you never
change you just keep taking care of your
family going to ecuador being tom cruise
eating your mom's food beating the [ __ ]
out of people i can't tell you how much
we're rooting for you here and you know
this appreciate it before we let you go
though i know you're sneaking your head
like me
we usually give sneakers on here uh
sometimes on short notice my boys at
suplex and philly can't make it in time
but for you we made it on time so i hope
you dig to the hope of your fan that i
have them there's some of my favorite
shoes that i own these are favorites i'm
gonna put on my feet
these are for you my man it's the least
i can do
i don't know if you're a yeezy fan but
these are the yeezy zebras i am now
they're also the comfiest shoe you ever
have oh yeah now you might get robbed in
ecuador wearing those so i don't leave
those here unless you have security
i will leave them here yeah man i'm
taking [ __ ] bites out there they're
the comfiest shoe in the world these
[ __ ] sweets they're also dope as hell
appreciate you deserve them everybody
like that i can't wait for you to beat
peter yawn man
i'm gonna get you to russian eyes bro
and right now that's hot take uh this
number five bantamweight in the world
number one in our hearts ladies and
gentlemen cheeto
[Laughter]
[Music]
but a bear boy
i need everything i get super thick boy